this is some mathematics by a guy who
was missed by a lot of people and his
name was Hippocrates but not the medic
lived at the same time but this was
Hippocrates of Chios the island Cheers
the medic was Hippocrates of course I
think Epocrates a mathematician deserves
an even bigger place in history and he
was missed and I explained one of the
things he did so this is called the meso
laid compass and what he did he took two
lines at an angle and you might say but
what angle it absolutely doesn't matter
but what you have to do is you have to
be accurate in this you couldn't mark
them off like a ruler and now you do the
same here it is now possible to multiply
any two numbers or divide any two
numbers just using lines so say we want
to multiply thirty four thousand six
hundred ninety two by three no hang on
hang on
three times four what you do is you find
three on this line and one on the bottom
line and you draw a line through it and
it gives you a picture of one three now
this is well BC long before Christ and
they're talking about massing pictures
wouldn't it be wonderful so we've got
one three but say we want four trees
what you do you find one two three four
on the bottom line and you need a set
square what you do you should place a
set square on that lines accurately Andy
yeah and then you slide it along the
ruler so it passes through the four and
you've done this right so that's a
parallel line that's a parallel line
they're both parallel and this goes
through that 12 and 3/4 to 12
not only that you're parallel lines give
you one three two three six three three
is nine four threes 12 five threes 15
isn't if you do division University
you're on wide 12 by four line through
the 12 and the four parallel line
through the one
we'll give you the answer three it's as
easy as that and it works for any
numbers all you need big lines but it's
the principle and the principle is so
simple
no wonder the Greeks didn't spend any
time at all in numeracy they were more
interested in geometry the shape of
maths this is the second idea from
Hippocrates a chioce and this is how to
find the square root of any number any
number Wow
just using a few lines a few curves
let's try say you want to find the
square root of 30 mm no 9 thank goodness
we know that one don't we okay let's
find it okay what you do is you produce
a line and you mark it off centimeter
it's fine that should be enough we want
the square root of 9 so starting them
there you count one two three four five
six seven eight nine now what you do now
is you add one and you might say why
well cuz that's what makes it work so
now you've got ten so a line of 10 with
five a center and five as radius you
produce a semicircle you can produce a
complete circle in alikes entirely up to
you and now with a set square you raise
the perpendicular from the nine and
where that line meets that point that
distance is the square root of nine or
in this case three centimeters that's
the length of that line the link that
line is three centimeters
exactly but that would have worked for
any number you like and that would of
course be in fractions if it was not a
square number yes so if I had asked you
to find the square root of a billion you
would have marked a billion and one as
yes so it gets impractical because
you've got a line with a billion
unit so it's impractical but the theory
works and they can practice it works and
I'll show you why we can join that to
that and you can see because the radius
of the circle is five and we chose nine
that's got to be four and that's got to
be three units okay and that's a 3 4 5
triangle or famous Pythagorean triangle
5 squared 25 equals 4 squared 16 plus 3
squared 9 but that wasn't the way this
was discovered and that isn't what he
used for the explanation what I've got
to do now is draw another one very
quickly don't worry about the lines now
the inspiration of this is this if we
draw a line there if we draw a line
across here what you produces two
triangles say leaves was the first known
Greek mathematician and he told you that
in a semi-circle any two lines from a
here and B here if they meet anyone on
my curve then that the angle they create
will be a right angle always and that is
so when we look at these two triangles
the angle there is equal to that angle
there that angle there equals that angle
there because the children add to a
right angle and that's a writing or
another idea so that means these two
triangles are similar there are
different size but their size are always
in the same proportion so let's say for
example that happened to be six units
and that happened to be three units if
that was three units and that was six
this would have to be twelve because
three to six is says six six to twelve
it's as simple as that if this was two
then it would be different two to six is
a six is to 18 yeah 206 s3 three sixes
or 18
so that was two and that was six that
would have to be 18 but if this was one
unit and that was six
this was have to be six sixes or 36 and
the whole length of course there will be
37 and that's why it works for any
number two square roots because because
you go in that way you're squaring so
coming back you square
okay and that's what you get and that's
where you get the square root and that
works now these two ideas have been
missed by many many mathematicians in
many many history books in many
collections of mathematicians in history
Hippocrates of chess was missed but he
was seen by renn a day car and a car
wrote a book called the geometry and
that is it in French and those are the
two designs okay and that's in French
and that's a translation in English from
the world of mathematics Newman's world
of mathematics volume 1 and what they
car said now do you see understanding
these as an introduction to geometry
he said if you understand your angles
the few lengths of lines you can
calculate absolutely anything and he was
wrong because at his time we hadn't
discovered calculus and calculus was
required to measure things that change
even as they change but that was the
kicker and he and Fermat started to look
for ways of measuring things that even
changed and Along Came Leibniz and Isaac
Newton and he produced calculus and from
then you could measure anything using
geometry
you know when brilliant are good enough
to sponsor one of our episodes I always
love searching their site to see what
they've got on the topic we just covered
and when it comes to square roots they
have a lot of stuff and I mean a lot of
stuff check it out people this is all
amazing intriguing content because
brilliant is a treasure trove of courses
and quizzes and all sorts of stuff just
like this don't just sit there watching
videos the best way to learn to get
smarter is to do stuff and brilliance
interactive website is well brilliant
for just that you can go check out
brilliant without any commitment but if
you do want to sign on for a premium
membership and unlock all the treasures
they've got go to brilliant org slash
numberphile because that's going to get
you 20% off there's a link down in the
description check out brilliant and now
thanks to them for supporting our
numberphile videos